[Music]
[Music]
that was the video for kids our born
stars the latest single from live off
his highly anticipated upcoming second
album and he joins me right now
congratulations thank you i'm stoked for
us because as fans we get to enjoy some
new music from ya the new album is out
august 5th right so excited you said
three days before your birthday three
days before my birthday what a gift i
know i'm excited you should be uh let's
talk about the title track first though
all for nothing because i feel like that
song is all about kind of surrendering
to love this was like about that kind of
stage where like okay like i'm really
falling and i have to just let go and
let it happen it almost feels like it's
so reflective of the album cover right
where you're just like all right this is
me surrendering right
[Music]
how would you say you have learned to
love yourself like what the what's the
secret honestly i feel like it's just in
the moment like realizing like
unconditional self-acceptance is like no
matter what i do i'm not gonna be
perfect i might say the wrong thing i
might not always you know what i mean
but like i'm gonna love myself
regardless and i don't know things like
meditation have been huge for me in that
um
and and honestly making this album a big
part of it was like getting back in
touch with my inner light and like my
childhood like wonder and stuff so yeah
i feel like that's such a gift as a
songwriter right to kind of get those
feelings out you know i'm like thank god
that i can do that like because what
else would you be doing i would just
because i just like spin in my head for
hours about stuff obviously you've also
been such a huge advocate of mental
health and have spoken out about your
experiences everyone has their situation
growing up around people
and their family or friends you know
struggling with mental health and i
think as i got older and i kind of
experienced my own like personal
all-time low and i was diagnosed with
depression and ocd and then was kind of
like hey like maybe you should try
medication and kind of around that time
and i started to become actually aware
of like what it meant to really you know
suffer like what does it mean to have
obsessive anxiety or like what does it
mean to be depressed versus sad yeah and
as i started to learn about it and as i
started to get better i was like one i
want to share this because like people
around me that were my friends sharing
their experiences with me were like the
things that got me through it and and
helped me figure out what was going on
with me
but also if i can share it you know just
with my audience and on social media and
stuff like maybe other people will find
bits and pieces that they can relate to
[Music]
at mental health it's like there's no
destination right it's a whole process
and a journey that ebbs and flows so i
think a lot of people can relate to your
journey you know and is it better to
write songs about like love and all this
happiness or heartbreak and like kind of
the dark side of life it's easier to
write the dark side because like for
example with my song i like me better
yes i wrote that after i got out of that
relationship and it was sort of like
romanticizing the beginning of it yeah
it's hard to write like happy things a
lot of the time i like being better when
i win the thing is like then you write a
song you put it out and it's stuck in
our heads
you know it's bob's i love
[Music]
it how would you say the experience of
writing and recording the second album
though compares to how i'm feeling the
last week yeah this one was well the
process was super different i like
honestly like
started it almost as a joke i was like i
want to learn how to freestyle rap and
like i'm not good at that like
definitely i have to admit i'm
definitely not going to die but you
tried it but i tried this yeah well
let's talk about the new single yeah out
now kids are born stars what was the
inspiration behind this track that one
was like a huge like me getting back in
touch with like my childhood self i was
doing a lot of like inner child
meditation and stuff like visualizing
and trying to learn lessons for me as
from like visualizing myself as a little
kid and i feel like i think of the song
as like a trade between like me finding
my imagination again today as you know
like i'm 27 now but also kind of like
trying to give that little kid version
of me a little bit of confidence because
it's like i always wanted to do music
and i always wanted to
you know be
this artist but i think back then i kind
of struggled with confidence a lot and
like you know still do now and so it's
sort of this yeah this like confidence
imagination
so then did you get to kind of translate
that visually like how did the music
video come yeah the video was like you
know we cast uh this amazing um kid who
is like playing like the little kid
version of me and it's kind of like the
videos like discovering that we're the
same person so it's like i'm kind of
like whoa like he's like passing out
these cds of his music like when he's a
little kid and he has a set crush on
this girl and like you know the other
kid like he wasn't able to get the cd to
her and it's a sort of journey of like
us interacting and like him showing me
like what it means to have imagination
again and then like me trying to give
him some confidence and make music
together and yeah
[Music]
we spoke to you recently at wingotingo
which i didn't realize was your first
show this year yeah it was just so crazy
i'm really excited especially too
because i have like i feel like i have
two full albums of like new music to
tour so how do you put the set list
together crazy well i did i did post on
my like instagram just like you know
what songs you guys want to see so i did
some of that and actually like the songs
that i naturally was already choosing
were a lot of the yeah
[Music]
haley kyoko is joining the tour i mean
she's also putting out some amazing new
music too yeah how excited are you guys
kind of like i don't know tour the world
together it's gonna it's gonna be sick
yeah i think it would be really sick if
we could you know maybe do some more
tour dates and stuff and um
so for fans who haven't been to a live
show what are they in for
a lot of ener it's
hectic in a good way
[Applause]
so you've already collaborated with so
many amazing artists i mean troye sivan
bts julia michaels you told us that
wayne go tango your dream list is
coldplay and drake yeah does drake know
about the freestyle wrapping oh my god
i actually i actually met drake in
passing at a sushi restaurant oh my god
i love it yeah that i was so nervous
yeah that would be that would be so sick
to work with drake someday i would be
starstruck
i was like the energy in the room was
just like it switches whoa yeah it was
crazy listen we're gonna manifest it for
you that's that energy we're gonna bring
into the studio let's go uh but there
aren't any collabs on this record right
no collabs okay and was that kind of
like a conscious decision yeah it was
kind of i mean part of it was just being
you know honestly by myself at home and
then some of it was like you know
because this album was very much about
me trying to get back in touch with like
ari like the the kid inside of me
i was like i just need to kind of like
do this myself a little bit and kind of
feel that out so does it feel like
probably one of your more personal
records today yeah yeah super personal
i'm like well i'm excited
congratulations all for nothing is out
august 5th and his north american tour
kicks off august 11. happy birthday to
you by the way thank you i love it uh
we're actually going to let love play us
out with more of his new single kids our
born stars we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
is
[Music]